hi I might see my from FX guide.com for
white reporting on the tech behind the
amazing spider-man 2 rise of electro in
the film mild-mannered engineer max
Dillon turns from spy man's greatest fan
into an electrically charged plasma
based supervillain after he falls into a
tank of genetically engineered eels and
it was down to Sony Pictures Imageworks
to transform the actor the Academy
award-winning Jamie Foxx into the
glowing transparent and lightening
charged electrode of course the
filmmakers looked at real lightning as
reference but they also looked at
neurological networks deep-space nebulas
and in particular the way that lightning
kind of lights up inside cloud banks
this drove the idea that electro was
actually flowing with energy and it's
firing and acting a bit like a storm
inside his body on set he after wore
elaborate special-effects makeup which
was the base for this visual effects
that would be added to later also I
guess it so does tracking markers
avoiding having to put dots all over
Jamie Foxx's face as the visual effects
would be combined with this real makeup
when he was actually hooded on set he
was actually lit up with a set of
remote-controlled LEDs this would avoid
his face from going very dark under that
hood when of course in reality in the
final version his face would actually be
emitting light from the base makeup
designed by K and B effects group the
digital elements were then added on top
as his mood changes the storm under his
skin also changes color and this is
particularly important because as he was
transparent the team had to model his
bones his veins and his organs as well
as provide blood for this energy to well
effectively light up the CG was then
composited with the original live-action
plate and then the final lightning
attacks added now these attacks were
animated not unlike spider-man's webs
but unlike those sort of single threads
these were actually multiple layers and
different stages from an initial pre
bolt arc and plasma to eight layers of
complex texture which when added with a
bunch of onset complex contact lighting
completed the sequence
well don't forget to subscribe for more
behind-the-scenes action unlike say more
for wide